Nous allons reprendre cet abordage de la lettre d'Epaul au Galate en restant encore sur son introduction, ces cinq premiers versets que nous venons de lire.
Et donc ce que nous avons déjà fait jusqu'ici, c'est très important. La problématique vécue par les Galates, c'est une problématique qui va faire partie des défis que l'Église va faire face pendant toute son histoire.
Et donc nous savons clairement que la pertinence de la lettre est très évidente.
Donc les risques, il est majeur, c'est le risque de la corruption, de la compréhension de l'Évangile pur et simple, du seul Évangile qui existe vraiment et du seul Évangile qui sauve.
Donc les enjeux ne peuvent pas être plus importants, sauf que pour dérouter cette Église, l'Église des Galates, de la compréhension du vrai Évangile,
ces faux maîtres, ces imposteurs qui sont arrivés, ils ont compris une stratégie qui est élémentaire et qui nous devraient faire attention.
Car ce n'est pas tout à fait évident pour l'Église.
Et ces hommes-là, ils arrivent en tant qu'émaitres en réclamant pour eux-mêmes de l'autorité.
Et donc ils vont vouloir miner, abîmer la confiance de cette Église dans l'autorité de l'apôtre Paul
afin de les dérouter du vrai Évangile et de faire qu'ils s'adaptent à une autre manière de se sauver
ou au moins de se maintenir dans les saluts.
Car ils ne vont pas enlever Christ complètement, mais ils vont dire Christ n'est pas suffisant,
vous avez besoin de revenir à la loi, vous avez besoin de vous circoncilier et reprendre toute cette emphase
sur les pratiques culturelles et rituelles de l'Ancien Testament.
Donc ce n'est pas que Jésus, c'est Jésus plus quelque chose d'autre, c'est Jésus plus les oeuvres.
Et donc Paul, il va adresser cette lettre pour corriger ces problèmes majeurs que l'Église traverse.
Et Paul, et c'est ça qu'on peut appeler en fait une introduction parfaite,
même déjà dans ses cinq premiers versets, nous allons constater qu'il est en train de présenter l'Évangile
d'une manière qui sera capable, qu'on fasse confiance à son appel apostolique,
l'autorité avec laquelle il présente son message,
mais aussi il déjà va définir l'essence de l'Évangile en démontrant que s'il faut que nous soyons sauvés,
il faut que ce soit exclusivement par la grâce des dieux,
à travers la foi dans l'œuvre parfaite en Jésus Christ.
Mais non seulement ça, non seulement pour les points de départ de notre foi,
les moments de notre conversion,
mais pour l'ensemble de la vie chrétienne,
c'est cet Évangile-là, non seulement qui nous a sauvés,
mais qui nous a assurés et qui agit constamment pour qu'on soit non seulement sauvés,
mais qu'on puisse sanctifier et progresser en sanctification et qu'on sera préservés.
Donc cette introduction, elle est magistrale, elle est parfaite, bien sûr elle est inspirée,
mais ce que nous sommes en train de considérer ici,
devant cette problématique de l'Église des Galates,
c'est de considérer vraiment qu'est-ce qui fait du ministère apostolique
quelque chose d'exclusif.
Et pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas retomber dans l'erreur des Galates
pour croire que même aujourd'hui on pourrait avoir des apôtres.
Et nous avons considéré quelles sont les implications
et pourquoi c'est non seulement suffisant,
cette génération d'apôtres bibliques du Nouveau Testament,
mais c'est même nécessaire que ce soit quelque chose d'exclusif
et d'une fois pour toutes.
Et donc, nous avons considéré tout au départ
c'est un homme qui passe presque inaperçu Paul.
Et donc là, Paul, il va presque oublier son identité
pour présenter son identité, son distinctif apostolique.
Sauf que même pour comprendre Paul l'apôtre,
c'est important de comprendre Paul l'homme.
Et on a vu que c'était un homme qui a un monument de la grâce de Dieu.
Même avant sa conversion, il était conscient
que Dieu était en train de les préparer.
Il était un homme magistral dans son humanité
et Dieu l'a formé dès le départ
pour accomplir une tâche exclusive.
car même si les apôtres ne pourraient pas l'être
sans cette œuvre des superintendances du Saint-Esprit,
cette onction qui reposait sur eux,
qui fait de leur ministère quelque chose d'exclusif,
des sangliers,
mais quand même, le Saint-Esprit faisait usage
d'un homme qui avait été formé par la souveraineté des dieux.
Donc par là, c'est important,
car même si nous devons considérer l'aspect exclusif de l'apostolat,
c'est important de voir aussi Paul avant tout
comme un modèle d'homme des dieux, des chrétiens,
quelqu'un qui a eu besoin de se convertir,
quelqu'un qui était un pécheur,
mais quelqu'un qui a aussi été conscient
de ses aptitudes, de son histoire
et comment Dieu a voulu utiliser son histoire
et ses capacités pour accomplir un but spécifique.
Et nous tous, nous avons des buts spécifiques
de la part de Dieu pour accomplir.
Et donc on a vu que Paul est un modèle d'homme chrétien,
mais aussi on a vu que la manière particulière
dont la vie de Paul a été conduite par Dieu
était déjà en train de remplir la préparation
pour qu'il s'est descendue,
pour qu'Apôtre, pour que Paul soit un apôtre,
soit accompli de manière particulière.
Et donc c'était très intéressant d'avoir traversé tout ça.
Et donc on s'est détourné un peu
du mouvement naturel de la lettre
pour considérer qui était Paul.
Et c'est super important pour nous
pour ne pas tomber dans la tentation catholique
de les voir tout simplement comme des supersants
très éloignés et sans voir l'humanité
qui sert des modèles pour nous.
Et ensuite, on a commencé à considérer
ces mouvements plus naturels de la lettre
qui nous présentent un Paul presque disparu
sous l'ombre de son apostolat.
Et donc c'est évident
que Paul doit agir ainsi
car l'attaque frontale
n'est pas un attaque tout simplement à Paul.
L'attaque frontale a des implications
pour l'évangile,
pour cette église
et pour toujours.
Et donc ce qu'on va voir,
c'est que Paul ici,
il va sortir à la défense
de son autorité apostolique
non pour défendre sa réputation tout simplement.
Il va sortir à la défense
de son autorité apostolique
car les enjeux sont
l'établissement des fondations de l'évangile
pour toute l'histoire de l'église.
Et donc Paul, il est ici en train de dire
je suis un représentant officiel,
je suis un apôtre avec un A majuscule,
je fais la distinction
entre ces soi-disant apôtres
et même j'ai fait la distinction
envers d'autres apôtres
dans l'essence minimal du terme,
des personnes qui vont sortir
pour représenter une église,
je suis là pour représenter directement
l'autorité divine
pour vous communiquer en évangile,
pour vous définir l'évangile,
pour vous expliquer l'évangile,
pour protéger l'évangile
et l'enregistrement
qui nous ont laissé les apôtres,
c'est la seule assurance qu'on a
pour toute l'histoire de l'église.
Et donc c'est très important pour nous
non seulement pour qu'on puisse considérer
quelque part cet appel
de l'apôtre Paul pour l'apostolat
et considérer quels sont les appels
que nous avons tous reçus,
car dans certains aspects,
cette vocation qu'a reçue Paul
pour un ministère exclusif,
nous pouvons noter dans nos vies,
nous devons chercher dans nos vies,
identifier de quelle manière
je peux lire mon histoire,
ma conversion
et comment je ressens l'appel des dieux
envers un service au sein de l'église.
Il y a des points là
que nous devons trouver d'identification.
Mais plus que ça,
c'est surtout pour considérer
l'importance
que notre foi,
que notre salut
soit fondée
dans les seuls évangiles
qui sauvent.
Et même si ce n'est pas
l'apôtre Paul
ou les apôtres
qui nous sauvent,
Dieu a décidé
de toujours sauver
exclusivement
à travers
ces messages
qui ont été définis
de manière inspirée
et inhérentes
par les apôtres.
Et donc,
c'est la foi
ou les fondements
de notre foi
qui nous a été laissés.
Et si
nous n'avions pas
des apôtres,
nous ne pourrions pas
faire confiance
à la parole de Dieu
aujourd'hui.
S'il n'y avait pas
quelque chose
de spécial
sur ces hommes-là
qui ont fait
l'intendance,
la supervision
et l'enregistrement
de la plupart
du Nouveau Testament,
nous ne pourrions avoir
aucune confiance
dans la parole de Dieu.
C'est les faits
qui ont été appelés
par un ministère
spécifique,
directement par Dieu,
afin d'établir
les fondements
de l'Évangile.
Et donc,
s'il n'y a pas eu
cette vocation particulière,
ces apôtres
avec un A majuscule,
nous n'avons
aucune assurance
dans la Bible.
Nous n'avons
aucune assurance
d'une superintendance
de la part du Saint-Esprit
avec cette onction
qui a reposé
sur les apôtres
pour interpréter
parfaitement l'Évangile,
pour enregistrer
pour démontrer,
pour protéger
et pour promouvoir
l'Évangile.
Au même temps,
si nous avons encore
des apôtres
jusqu'aujourd'hui,
nous n'avons pas
besoin de la Bible.
Donc,
d'un côté,
on ne peut pas
faire confiance à la Bible
car il n'y a pas
d'autorité,
d'inspiration.
De l'autre côté,
s'il y a encore
des apôtres,
nous n'avons pas
forcément besoin
de la Bible.
C'est la Bible
plus ce qui dit
l'apôtre.
Et ce qui dit l'apôtre
devrait être rajouté
dans la parole
des dieux.
Et donc,
si c'est le cas,
nous n'avons finalement
aucune autorité
objective absolue
qui puisse
déterminer
les paramètres
pour l'Église,
pour notre vie,
pour la foi.
et on a considéré
en fait
que ce qui fait
de l'œuvre
des apôtres
une œuvre
pour toujours
définie
et pour toujours
exclusive,
c'est qu'ils ont
établi
une fondation,
c'est le langage
biblique
que les apôtres
vont employer
eux-mêmes
par rapport à son œuvre.
C'est-à-dire
que l'Église
puisse voir
comment on va bâtir
tous ses fondements
mais que personne
n'ose changer
les fondements.
Les fondements
n'ont aucune
nécessité,
aucun besoin
d'amélioration,
d'évolution,
de nouvelles révélations.
Pour ce qui concerne
la définition
de l'Évangile,
nous avons
besoin
que ce soit
quelque chose
de défini
pour toujours.
Nous pouvons grandir
dans notre compréhension
et l'Église
sera pour toujours
bâtie sur les fondements
des apôtres.
Donc,
en ayant
considéré
cette vérité centrale,
la vocation apostolique
et responsable
pour établir
les fondements
de notre foi,
c'est la vérité
centrale pour nous,
pour élargir un peu,
la vocation apostolique
est responsable
pour établir
les fondements
de notre foi
et tous les chrétiens
seront sauvés,
protégés
et développés
par Jésus-Christ
à travers
l'œuvre
exclusive
des apôtres.
C'est
en persévérant
dans la doctrine
des apôtres
que nous allons
continuer à grandir
dans notre foi,
c'est en proclamant
l'Évangile
telle qu'est définie
par les apôtres
que les personnes
seront sauvées.
Et donc,
nous devrions,
donc l'Église,
chaque nom de l'Église
devrait avoir
pleine conviction
de l'exclusivité
de la vocation apostolique.
et la question clé
pour nous,
c'est qu'est-ce qui fait
de la vocation apostolique
son exclut...
qu'est-ce qui fait
que la vocation apostolique
soit exclusive
à la lumière
de ses passages,
de l'expérience
de l'apôtre Paul,
à la lumière
de la manière
dont Paul
est en train
de défendre
son apostolat.
Car ici,
à nouveau,
Paul est en train
de démontrer
qu'il n'est pas
un apôtre
comme n'importe qui,
il pouvait se réclamer
un apôtre,
mais il est
un apôtre
comme les douze
et il est un apôtre
particulièrement appelé
de cette manière.
Donc,
il est en train
de présenter
pourquoi nous devons
les considérer
et pourquoi il est
vraiment un apôtre
dans les sens
les plus plans
du terme.
Et donc,
nous allons considérer
deux réponses.
L'une,
on a déjà fait,
c'est l'exclusivité
de la vocation
en soi,
donc la manière
dont les apôtres
ont été appelés
pour être des apôtres.
Cela ne sera jamais
répété dans l'histoire
et ne sera jamais
répété dans l'histoire.
Personne ne peut
réclamer avoir traversé
ces que nous voyons
dans l'appel
des Paul
et dans l'appel des douze.
Car même Paul,
lorsqu'il va faire référence
à son apostolat
dans d'autres passages,
il va laisser très clair
qu'il est né
comme en avortant
hors du temps.
C'est-à-dire,
s'il est né déjà
hors du temps,
c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel,
d'especial,
et nous ne pouvons pas
attendre que cela
se passe à nouveau.
Et plus que ça,
la nécessité en soi
que l'évangile
soit défini
d'une fois pour toujours
et que l'histoire
de l'Église
soit là pour démontrer
que toutes les corrections
qui ont été portées
au long de l'histoire
étaient de revenir
au fond des mois
des apôtres,
démontrent
que nous ne pouvons pas
attendre
que des nouveaux apôtres
apparaissent.
Et donc par là,
l'exclusivité
de la vocation en soi,
c'est la première chose
qui Paul va mettre en emphase.
Verset 1,
Paul, apôtre,
non de la part des hommes,
ni par un homme,
mais par Jésus-Christ
et Dieu le Père
qui l'a ressuscité
d'entre les morts.
Donc,
ce qu'il est en train
de dire,
je vais prendre déjà
la conception
des ressurrections
pour dire
Dieu lui-même
avait confirmé
que c'est le seul moyen
efficace pour les saluts.
Aucun prophète,
aucun personnage
de l'Ancien Testament
n'a traversé
la ressurrection
à cause de son observation
de la loi.
Et Christ,
notamment car il a été capable
d'accomplir parfaitement
la loi,
car il a accompli
cette œuvre,
il est ressuscité
car Dieu a confirmé
que son œuvre
était parfaite.
Donc, la seule base
véritable pour les vrais saluts,
et c'est intéressant
car dans la définition
de son apostolat,
dans la présentation
nous ne voyons pas
de référence directe
de l'apôtre Paul
à la loi.
Il est en train
de combattre
ces hommes
qui veulent revenir
à la loi.
Et même si c'est
quelque chose
d'implicite là,
on sait que Jésus
a accompli parfaitement
la loi,
Paul ne va pas faire
de référence à ça.
Et ce qu'il est en train
de dire,
c'est Jésus-Christ
ressuscité,
des morts,
s'est présenté devant moi,
selon la volonté
du Père,
l'origine de son appel,
c'était de la part
des dieux,
directement,
à travers la manifestation
du Dieu,
les fils,
Christ, Jésus,
ressuscité,
afin que Paul soit
d'une fois pour toutes
complètement assuré
que cet évangile
est vrai.
Donc, par connaissance,
par expérience,
par cette visitation
du Christ,
il était complètement
conscient
qu'il a reçu
cette commission
pour représenter
de manière
autoritative,
avec toute l'autorité
pleine,
non tout simplement
la représentation
d'une église
qui a son autorité
en tant qu'ambassade.
Mais il avait
une autorité
qui surmonte
quelque part
l'autorité
de l'église.
il avait cette autorité
de représenter
Dieu lui-même,
Christ lui-même
et lorsqu'il parle
sous inspiration divine
en tant qu'apôtre,
en accomplissant sa vocation,
ce qu'il parle
est la parole
des dieux.
Ce n'est pas son opinion,
c'est la parole
des dieux.
Et donc là,
on voit
qu'il avait
cette conscience
fraîche
et pour toujours
de sa commission
car imaginez-vous
d'avoir été
commissionné
par cette autorité
magistrale
du Christ glorifié
un privilège
qui même
les autres apôtres
n'ont pas eu.
C'est pour ça
que son sens
de rédivabilité
est constant.
Paul va
se perdre,
va perdre
son identité
dans sa vocation
et sa vocation
c'est de disparaître
pour représenter
l'autorité d'un autre.
Et donc là,
par expérience,
par onction
du Saint-Esprit,
il a eu cette capacité
de comprendre
l'Évangile
et d'exposer
l'Évangile.
Donc,
la vocation apostolique
est d'appel
exclusive
par sa vocation,
par son appel
qui est d'origine directe
et qu'il a reçu
par Jésus-Christ.
Jésus-Christ
a commissionné
personnellement
tous les vrais apôtres.
Personnellement.
Et il a,
il s'est manifesté,
ressuscité
à tous les vrais apôtres.
Il l'appelle
des Paul particulièrement
pour être un apôtre.
C'était commissionné
directement
par Jésus-Christ
ressuscité.
Donc,
l'appel
est d'exclusive
origine divine
et c'est un appel
corroboré
par l'Église.
Donc,
qu'est-ce que je veux dire
par là ?
C'est quelque chose
de très important
car il va dire
apôtres,
non de la part des hommes
ni de la part d'un homme
mais par Jésus-Christ
et Dieu le Père
qui l'a ressuscité
des morts
et tous les frères
qui sont avec moi
aux Églises de la Galatie.
Donc,
ce qu'il peut faire,
c'est qu'il peut faire
tous les frères
qui sont avec moi.
Il est en train de dire
je ne néglige pas
l'importance
de l'autorité locale,
d'une Église locale
ou des Églises locales
qui puissent être confirmées.
les fruits
de mon ministère
confirment
mon autorité apostolique,
corroborent
mon autorité apostolique.
Ce que Paul
est en train
de nous enseigner,
c'est,
par exemple,
d'avant
de prendre sérieusement
les accusations
ou les critiques
de quelqu'un,
posez-vous la question
où sont les fruits ?
Sont ces fruits authentiques ?
Quelle est l'Église locale
qui est en train
de supporter
les ministères
de cette personne ?
C'est très facile
de réclamer une autorité,
basée sur des dégrés théologiques,
basée sur influence numérique,
basée sur une base digitale.
Mais la question
qu'on doit se poser,
c'est,
où est l'Église ?
Où sont les frères
et sœurs authentiques
qui puissent certifier
que cette œuvre
est une œuvre divine ?
Et donc,
ce que nous sommes
en train de voir ici,
c'est qu'il pôle
les plus probable,
c'est qu'il soit
avec une équipe
des frères
qui soient
les plus sains,
si on peut dire comme ça,
possiblement ceux
qui ont ramené
les nouvelles
des Galates
à Paul
et qui étaient
aussi étonnés
que Paul.
Paul,
ils sont en train
de se distancier
du vrai évangile.
Ils sont en train
de s'éloigner,
s'écarter
du vrai évangile.
Et donc,
c'était des hommes
mûrs dans la foi.
Aussi,
l'équipe
avec qui Paul
voyageait
pour faire
ses voyages missionnaires.
Donc,
une équipe
assez solide
et,
possiblement aussi,
l'église
là où il était.
Probablement,
Antioche,
une église locale
à laquelle Paul lui-même,
même en tant qu'apôtre,
était connecté
et d'une certaine manière
soumis aussi
à son autorité.
Mais ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que pour plus
que cet aspect
doit valoir pour nous
jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
avant d'ordonner
quelqu'un en tant que
ministre de l'évangile,
avant d'envoyer
quelqu'un en tant qu'évangéliste
soit missionnaire,
cette personne doit
démontrer des fruits
au sein d'une église
et l'église doit confirmer.
Et le mieux d'entre nous
doit aussi confirmer.
Et quand je dis mieux,
ce n'est pas en termes
des performances individuelles,
c'est juste maturité
dans la foi,
connaissance biblique,
etc.
Sensibilité
pour pouvoir constater
qu'il s'agit
d'une œuvre authentique.
Pour tous les ministres,
pour la suite
de l'histoire de l'église,
il faut que l'église
soit là
en train de confirmer
et même si ce n'est pas
inhérent,
nous ne sommes pas cibles
des erreurs
à ce niveau-là.
C'est possible
que les personnes nous trompent
et la réalité,
c'est que même si
nous sommes passifs
des fautes,
la réalité,
c'est que c'est
la manière la plus fiable
qu'une église
en bonne santé
puisse reconnaître
l'appel de quelqu'un.
Mais plus que ça,
Paul,
au même temps
qu'il est en train
de dire
l'autorité de cette église
corrobore mon ministère,
il est en train de dire
au même temps
en tant qu'apôtre,
moi,
je suis une autorité
même au-dessus
de l'église
quelque part.
Je suis
le fondateur
quelque part,
je vais poser
les fondements.
À nouveau,
ce n'est pas
que l'œuvre
des apôtres
s'ouvre,
mais les apôtres
ont été appelés
pour représenter
cette autorité,
établir les bases
et les paramètres
pour toujours.
Et c'est pour ça
qui, Paul,
vite fait,
en ayant
mis l'emphase
sur l'importance
de reconnaître
l'autorité
de l'église,
des frères et sœurs,
il va reprendre,
et c'est une mention
assez courte
par rapport
à d'autres lettres
qu'il fait
à ses frères-là,
mais à partir de là,
il va reprendre
en première personne
car aucune chose
ne peut ébranler,
diminuer
les tons
de sa correction.
Et il n'est pas là
pour corriger
tout simplement
selon l'opinion
des frères et sœurs.
il est là
pour corriger
selon les représentants
ambassadeurs
par excellence
des dieux les pères
et des dieux les fils.
Donc Paul,
il est ici,
il va bientôt dire
« je suis étonné »
et il va continuer
la lettre
en première personne.
Et sans l'identité
à nouveau,
disparu
par sa vocation,
par son apostolat.
Et donc Paul,
il va reprendre
cette autorité suprême
et donc ce qui fait
de l'appel apostolique
un appel exclusif,
c'est,
premier grand élément,
c'est la vocation apostolique,
un appel direct
de la part des dieux
d'origine divine
par Jésus-Christ
corroboré par l'Église.
D'accord ?
Et la douzième
grande réponse
que nous allons considérer
aujourd'hui,
c'est que ce qui fait
de la vocation apostolique
exclusive,
c'est la commission
de la tâche
particulière des apôtres.
Les apôtres ont reçu
une tâche
qui personne
ne sera plus capable
d'accomplir
et dont on n'a plus besoin
même que quelqu'un
accomplisse.
Et la réalité,
c'est que les apôtres
ont été commissionnés
pour définir,
protéger
et promouvoir
l'Évangile.
Pour élargir un peu
cette compréhension,
les apôtres ont été
commissionnés
directement par Dieu,
ils ont été capacités
par Dieu,
les Saint-Esprits,
pour définir,
protéger
et promouvoir
de manière inhérente
l'Évangile
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
Dieu,
les Fils.
Vous comprenez ?
Dieu a décidé
de séparer un nombre
des personnes,
des hommes,
sur qui son Saint-Esprit
allait reposer,
surtout lorsqu'il serait
en train d'accomplir
leur tâche apostolique,
afin que d'une fois
pour toutes,
l'Évangile soit
définie
et qu'il puisse aussi
nous laisser un modèle
parfait
de comment protéger
l'Évangile
et comment promouvoir
l'Évangile.
Et c'est exactement
ce qu'il est en train
de faire ici,
dans cette introduction.
Il est en train
de définir
et ça c'est exclusif
aux apôtres.
Nous n'avons aucun droit
d'essayer de définir
l'Évangile.
Il doit définir
l'Évangile
avec clarté,
dans sa simplicité,
dans sa profondeur,
avec concision
et avec
larges explications.
Il est en train
de définir
comme les autres apôtres
l'ont fait aussi.
Nouveau Testament,
œuvre accomplie,
œuvre parfaite.
Mais ils sont là aussi
pour promouvoir
et protéger
et eux,
ils ont fait cela
avec perfection.
Et voilà pourquoi
nous avons toutes les lettres
du Lévo Testament.
Pour qu'on apprenne
que nous devons aussi
continuellement
dans notre vie
protéger
et promouvoir
les vrais Évangiles,
l'Évangile des apôtres.
Il y a quelque chose
qui continue pour nous,
mais il y a quelque chose
dont nous avons besoin
d'apprendre
qui nous a été laissé
par les apôtres.
C'est très important
dès le départ
de remarquer
dans cette introduction
que Paul va faire
une présentation
de la définition
de l'Évangile
de manière magistrale
et c'est magistral
par son inhérence,
par sa concision,
par sa précision
et en même temps,
en faisant
cette manière particulière
pour définir l'Évangile,
il est en train
de corriger
pas mal de choses,
il est en train
de protéger
et promouvoir
l'Évangile
chez les Galates.
Et donc,
ici,
nous devons garder
dans nos esprits
qui définir,
c'est différent,
de créer.
Il n'est pas en train
de créer l'Évangile,
il est en train
de définir l'Évangile.
C'est différent
d'inventer,
il n'est pas en train
de produire l'Évangile
par son imagination
et c'est surtout
glorieux
de comparer
l'explication
de l'Évangile
et la définition
entre les écrits
apostoliques
partout dans
le Nouveau Testament
et de voir
combien
l'harmonie,
nous ne voyons pas
des différences
en termes
de définition.
Nous pouvons voir
comment
certains aspects
sont plus mis
en phase,
plus enrichis,
nous pouvons voir
toutes les couleurs
d'une définition
de l'Évangile
mais l'Évangile
elle est même.
Donc définition
n'est pas d'améliorer
ni de développer
car l'Évangile
n'est pas passible
d'amélioration.
Définir
n'est pas
d'exercer
son opinion
comme parfois
nous pensons
que nous pouvons
diverger d'opinion
par rapport
aux écrits apostoliques.
Non mais mon Dieu
n'est pas comme ça,
tu sais,
il n'est pas si sévère,
il n'est pas si sans.
Ce n'est pas ça
qui l'attendait tous.
Nous n'avons aucun droit
de diverger
car
la définition
de l'Évangile
apostolique
n'est pas la définition
de leur Évangile,
c'est la définition
de l'Évangile
de Jésus-Christ.
Et donc,
c'est une définition
parfaite.
Et donc,
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ?
Ils ont pris
ce qui était parfait
et ils ont présenté
en toute sa pureté,
perfection,
simplicité,
profondeur
et avec toutes
ses implications.
Voilà pourquoi
l'histoire
de l'Église
sera toujours
résumée
sur
nous sommes en train
de continuer
à bâtir
sur les fondements
des apôtres.
Le plus
notre œuvre
est conforme
à ces
héritages
que les apôtres
nous ont laissés,
le plus
la vie chrétienne
aura de la qualité.
Mais au moins,
toutes les Églises authentiques
doivent avoir
un même fondement.
Si le fondement
n'est pas là,
nous ne sommes pas
devant la vraie Église.
Et non seulement
l'histoire de l'Église,
mais l'histoire
de chaque chrétien
sera plus ou moins
profitable
selon sa conformité
et comment
nous baptisons
nos vies
sur les fondements
des apôtres.
Qu'est-ce que
les apôtres ont
enregistré
par rapport
à comment
je dois me porter
au sein de ma famille,
à la société,
au travail,
à l'université,
en tant qu'homme,
en tant que femme,
en tant que mari,
en tant qu'épouse.
Si
j'ose
à ne pas
m'adapter
aux enseignements
apostoliques,
même si je suis
bâti
sur les vrais fondements,
je ne suis pas
sous les risques
de perdre mon salut,
mais je suis
dans un grand danger
de vivre
une vie
souffrante,
profondément abîmée.
Et c'est surtout
les jours
de l'affliction
qui démontrera
l'œuvre de chacun.
J'ai bâti
les fondements
de l'apôtre Paul
comme un prudent
constructeur,
que chacun voit
comment il édifie
là-dessus.
et c'est
les jours
de la difficulté
qui va démontrer
quelle est la qualité
de notre foi,
même si la foi
elle est là présente
et évidente.
Et donc,
autant pour l'histoire
de l'Église
comme pour
notre vie personnelle,
c'est très important
de reconnaître
cette œuvre
des apôtres,
cette tâche exclusive
de définir
l'Évangile.
Et donc,
les apôtres
ont été commissionnés
directement par Dieu
et capacités
pour définir,
protéger,
promouvoir l'Évangile
de manière inhérente.
Que pouvons-nous dire
de la définition apostolique
de l'Évangile ?
Et c'est ça
que je veux considérer
avec vous
d'ici vers la fin
de la prédication.
Quelle est
la définition apostolique
de l'Évangile biblique ?
Donc,
la première chose
que nous allons voir
et donc,
il faut remarquer
non seulement
les contenus
mais aussi
la manière
de définir l'Évangile.
Car comme on a étudié
récemment
sur l'évangélisation
au sein de l'Église
de Bonne Nouvelle,
on a considéré
l'importance
que les messages
soient communiqués.
Donc,
nous devons être
en témoignage de l'Évangile
mais il ne suffit pas
de ne pas utiliser les mots.
Juste de donner
un bon exemple.
L'Évangile est un message
défini à être proclamé
et il faut qu'on ait
cette capacité
et ça nous aide
beaucoup en fait
de savoir présenter
de manière concise
l'Évangile.
Et ici,
Paul
va nous présenter
une définition
qui sera quelque part
la base
sur laquelle
il va
développer
tous ses arguments
pendant toute la lettre
des Galates.
Dès le point de départ.
Et c'est ça
que c'est magistral.
Donc,
il va dire
Paul,
apôtre,
non de la part des hommes
ni par un homme
mais par Jésus-Christ
et Dieu le Père
qui l'a ressuscité
d'entre les morts.
Autorité apostolique.
Et tous les frères
qui sont avec moi
aux églises
de la Galatie.
Et là,
il commence
à présenter l'Évangile.
Que la grâce
et la paix
vous soient données
de la part des dieux,
les Pères
et de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
qui s'est donné lui-même
pour nos péchés
afin de nous arracher
du présent siècle mauvais
selon la volonté
de notre Dieu
et Père
à qui soit la gloire
aux siècles des siècles.
Amen.
La première vérité
c'est que l'essence
de l'Évangile
est la grâce
et la paix
des dieux
et du Christ.
L'essence
de l'Évangile
est la grâce
et la paix des dieux.
Si on voulait demander
à ce que tu peux résumer
l'Évangile
en deux mots
Paul répondrait
grâce et paix.
Et pourquoi
cette capacité
et pourquoi
cette efficacité
pour porter
la correction
envers les Galates ?
Cette capacité
consiste
de présenter
l'Évangile
c'est car
l'essence
le résumé
de l'Évangile
c'est
une action
gracieuse
des dieux
envers nous
pour établir
une réconciliation
envers lui
pour qu'ils nous ayons
et expérimentons
un état
de paix
envers Dieu
mais non seulement
mais par la réconciliation
avec Dieu
nous sommes réconciliés
avec nous-mêmes
avec l'autre
nous sommes réconciliés
avec l'univers
car
la réalité
de la présente
condition de l'humanité
c'est
que nous sommes
un initié
envers Dieu
envers nous-mêmes
envers les autres
et envers
même la planète
et l'univers
et la réalité
c'est que
grâce et paix
nous parlent
du cadre général
de la condition
totale
de la conversion
et de toute la continuité
de la vie du chrétien
c'est super important
de remarquer
la grâce
est la source
et les traitements
qu'on va recevoir
pendant toute notre vie
avec Dieu
depuis la conversion
c'était grâce
on était perdus
il est venu vers nous
par sa grâce
pendant toute la vie
chrétienne
c'est qu'on doit
s'anticiper
du traitement
des dieux
envers nous
c'est grâce
en faveur
imméritée
de la part des dieux
et là
et voilà pourquoi
il va présenter
un parallèle
qui est très
recourant ici
dans les passages
Dieu le Père
Dieu le Fils
donc la grâce
étant
prédominamment
la manifestation
de la détermination
de la volonté
du Père
envers son peuple élu
donc c'est les Pères
qui ont décidé
d'agir avec
de la grâce
envers nous
et Jésus Christ
bien sûr
qui en agissant
par grâce
il a fait quelque chose
qui a rendu possible
que cette réconciliation
ait lieu
et donc il est venu
pour être
les princes de la paix
il est venu
pour établir
la réconciliation
dans son sang
donc grâce
et paix
mais à partir du moment
où la grâce
est déclenchée
envers nous
et exécutée
par Jésus
tous les cadres
dans lesquels
la vie chrétienne
sera vécue
c'est un cadre
d'un traitement
et d'une expérience
qui doit être constante
et toujours vivante
dans les cas
de chrétien
qu'est-ce qu'on reçoit
des dieux
grâce et paix
est-ce que c'est
l'expérience
que vous avez
ce n'était pas
l'expérience
qui caractérisait
les galates
à ce moment
car s'ils ont tombé
dans la tentation
de suivre
leurs performances
des rituels
ou d'autres moyens
pour se trouver
plus en paix
avec Dieu
ou pour
penser qu'ils pourraient
par là provoquer
la grâce des dieux
envers eux
en faveur des dieux
si ce n'était pas basé
sur une grâce
d'origine divine
et une réconciliation
en Jésus Christ
ils sont déjà
en train de sortir
du cadre
de la grâce
et de la paix
des dieux
c'est super intéressant
de remarquer
l'essence de l'évangile
c'est la grâce
et la paix
Lightfoot
il va dire
la grâce
est la fontaine
de toutes les bonnes choses
qu'on reçoit
et la paix
est la couronne
de toutes les bénédictions
c'est
l'état
de l'âme
du chrétien
qu'on devrait avoir
pendant toute notre vie
chrétienne
car c'est
la prédisposition
divine
inébranlable
envers ses enfants
il a décidé
de nous adopter
en tant que père
plus tard
Galate
Paul va décrire
la distinction
entre un esclave
de la loi
et un enfant
adopté par les pères
si l'esclave
désobéit la loi
!
il peut même être
chassé
abandonné
sortir
mais un enfant
ne sera jamais
abandonné par son père
même s'il désobéit
nous allons recevoir
un autre traitement
et donc là
c'est cette assurance là
dans les cadres
de la présentation essentielle
cette introduction
de l'évangile
commence par là
sauf que cette présentation
résumée de l'évangile
par ces deux termes
n'est pas seulement
quelque chose
qui nous donne
la définition essentielle
de l'évangile
et voilà pourquoi
c'est très important
de savoir utiliser
les termes bibliques
avec la définition biblique
car les termes bibliques
lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
remplis du contenu biblique
c'est d'idolâtrie
ça ne sert à rien
de répéter
gloire, gloire, gloire
grâce
miséricorde
si on n'a pas la compréhension
ni des termes
ni comment
l'oeuvre de Jésus Christ
est attachée
à ces termes
et lorsqu'ils nous
nous lions
toujours
l'oeuvre de Dieu
à travers Jésus Christ
à ces conceptions
il y a une richesse
énorme
des compréhensions
et c'est un impact
glorieux pour nos vies
et ce que nous voyons ici
c'est que
l'évangile peut être
défini par ces deux termes
mais il a une fonction
aussi
des corrections
c'est à dire
Paul
il va écrire
l'une des lettres
les plus enflammées
en colère
avec déception
pour corriger une église
mais en même temps
ce qu'il va anticiper
c'est les cadres d'amour
donc Paul
il n'est pas seulement
en train de parler
des grâces et paix
il est en train d'incarner
la grâce et la paix
de Dieu
il est en train de représenter
l'autorité des dieux
et du Christ
envers cette église
qui est dans une grande erreur
mais il est en train
de les faire
avec une attitude pacifique
avec une attitude
qui cherche
à maintenir
et à préserver
cette église
dans la grâce des dieux
et donc là
c'est super important
il dit
avant de dire
je suis étonné
il va dire
que la grâce
et la paix
des dieux notre père
et Jésus Christ
soit avec vous
et donc ce qu'il est en train
de faire
c'est
soyez rassurés
et c'est intéressant
quand il dit
aux églises
de la Galatie
et ça c'est déjà
une démonstration incroyable
des grâces
car
ici
ils sont
au bord
des touchés
au fondement
de l'évangile
au bord
de se laisser
circoncire
mais
le fondement
de l'évangile
n'a pas été encore
touché
ou ébranlé
et pour plus
disforme
qu'il soit
cette église
pour plus grave
qu'il soit
ses erreurs
pendant que
Paul puisse voir
que les fondements
sont encore là
il ne va pas
traiter ces églises là
comme si elles n'étaient pas
des vraies églises
elles vont faire
une distinction
importante
entre les traitements
de l'apôtre Paul
envers
les églises
aux Galates
et la condition
de l'église catholique
en démontrant
c'est une grande générosité
de l'apôtre Paul
qu'il puisse
maintenir un avis
envers cette église
en tant qu'église
car il y avait encore
l'espoir des corrections
les fondements
n'ont pas été touchés
mais quand on considère
que les fondements
sont changés
c'est à partir
de ces points là
et c'est moi
qui dis ça
c'est à partir
de ces points là
où nous ne pouvons pas
reconnaître une église
en tant qu'authentique
comme c'était
le cas
pour les réformateurs
qui sont venus après
car jusqu'à la phase là
où on avait
Calvin-Luther
les documents
confessionnels catholiques
n'avaient pas
encore été changés
dans la pratique
oui
mais pas
dans les documents
confessionnels
mais après
les conciles des 30
c'est là
où ils vont élever
l'autorité du pape
la même autorité
de la Bible
les traditions
et prendre les livres
apocryphes
et les rendre
comme s'ils étaient inspirés
et là
les fondements
de l'évangile
l'autorité de l'évangile
elle est touchée
donc là
nous ne pouvons plus
reconnaître
les personnes peuvent
bien sûr
se convertir
car il y a quand même
un peu de l'évangile
qui peut être
sous les combles là
mais la réalité
c'est que nous n'avons pas
le droit de reconnaître
une église
en tant qu'authentique
si l'évangile
dans son essence
est touché
et la réalité
c'est qu'ici
il est en train
de se diriger
à cette église
avec beaucoup
de géographie
grâce et paix
envers vous
Dieu est votre père
je suis en train
de vous rappeler
quel est l'essence
de l'évangile
quel est le cadre
comment cette paix
a été acquise
comment cette grâce
a été manifestée
quelle était
votre condition
si lorsque vous étiez
complètement perdu
Dieu agit avec grâce
envers vous
combien plus maintenant
il ne sera
gracieux envers vous
vous n'avez pas besoin
d'autre chose
qu'est Christ
pour vous sanctifier
mais en même temps
cette grâce
n'était pas
partielle
cette paix
n'était pas
partielle
c'est ce que
Paul est en train
de faire ici
il est en train
d'anticiper
grâce et paix
pour définir
son objectif
pour communiquer
authentiquement
sa générosité
envers cette église
mais il va faire
la distinction
entre aimer
objectiver
les biens
de cette église
et notamment
pour objectiver
les biens
de cette église
pour la préserver
dans les cadres
de la grâce
et de la plaie
il y a un seul lieu
un seul endroit
au monde
où nous trouvons
vraiment la grâce
et la paix
des dieux
et c'est sous les ailes
de Jésus Christ
et c'est que
Paul est en train
de faire
il est en train
de commencer
par nous rappeler
du cadre
de la grâce
et faire la connexion
directe
avec l'oeuvre
de Jésus Christ
ce qu'il est en train
de faire
bientôt
c'est cette paix
inébranlable
c'est une paix
qu'on puisse projeter
pour toute la vie
mais c'est un pôle
avec son autorité
apostolique
enflammée
qui va dire
je m'étonne
et qui va lancer
coup après coup
pour corriger
cette église
donc l'environnement
n'est pas
le plus paisible
possible
c'est un environnement
où les nouées
commencent à se charger
où les tonnerres
sont déjà là
ne touchez pas
à l'évangile
sinon
grâce et paix
ce n'est pas
l'environnement
pour vous
qu'il soit
anathème
ceux qui présentent
un faux évangile
et ce qu'il peut
être en train de faire
avec les Galactes
c'est de dire
soyez sûr
que c'est pour
que vous maintenez
sous la grâce
de Dieu
mais c'est cette
correction
envers toutes
les aberrations
cette condémation
envers toutes
les aberrations
qu'une église
même si authentique
dans son fondement
doit être réprochée
et même par
une attitude
en colère
des justes indignations
c'est l'état
d'esprit
de l'apôtre Paul
à ce moment
et quel est l'objectif
c'est de non seulement
nous rappeler
comment cette grâce
a été affichée
comment cette paix
a été acquise
mais c'est pour pousser
les Galates
par cette autorité
apostolique
c'est de pousser
les Galates
à revenir
sous les ailes
de Jésus Christ
la tempête
elle est là
mais le seul lieu
pour rester gardé
par la grâce
et la paix
de Dieu
n'est pas auprès
des rituels
des circoncisions
c'est
notamment
sous les ailes
du Christ
donc l'essence
de l'évangile
c'est grâce
et paix
le fondement
de l'évangile
est l'oeuvre
substitutive
du Christ
Paul va dire
au verset 3
de la part
de Dieu
les Pères
et notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
qui s'est donné
lui-même
pour nos péchés
afin de nous arracher
du présent siècle
le mauvais
selon la volonté
de notre Dieu
et Père
à qui soit la gloire
au siècle des siècles
Amen
donc
et de la part
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
qui s'est donné
lui-même
pour nos péchés
et donc
les fondements
de l'évangile
est l'oeuvre
substitutive du Christ
comment cette paix
a été acquise
comment cette grâce
a été affichée
c'était à travers
l'envoi
de la part du Père
de son fils
et donc
les fils
qui est venu
pour
s'est donné
lui-même
pour nos péchés
donc
Christ ici
est mis en avance
grâce et paix
ne peut pas être
comprise
à part Christ
et exclusivement
par Christ
Christ est mis en avance
car tout
tout éloignement
tout égarement
de la suffisance
et de l'exclusivité
de l'oeuvre
de Jésus Christ
pour nous sauver
est une démonstration
avant tout
d'un mépris
envers la personne
de Jésus Christ
nous commençons
à être tentés
à nous éloigner
nous commençons
à être tentés
même
intellectuellement
à embrasser
certains cris
certains doutes
nous commençons
à
nous exposer
au danger
de l'influence
des fausses doctrines
car Christ
a déjà délaissé
la place
d'adoration
dans nos cœurs
la relation
expérimentale
avec Jésus Christ
c'est ce qui nous garde
de tous les types
de tentations
qui soit
la tentation
d'une hérésie
d'une mauvaise
compréhension
de la foi
c'est car
on a déjà développé
une nouvelle passion
un nouveau idole
un nouvel idole
et donc
ce que Paul
est en train de faire
c'est de remettre
Jésus Christ
exposer Jésus Christ
à nouveau
comme celui
qui s'est donné
lorsqu'il est venu
accomplir les saluts
il n'est pas venu
nous offrir
des nouveaux
dix commandements
une nouvelle loi
il n'est pas venu
pour nous sauver
et apporter la paix
il n'est pas venu
nous présenter
des nouvelles méthodes
pour la sanctification
de rajouter des lois
par rapport
à la manière
dont on doit s'habiller
il n'a pas mis
des poids
ou d'emphase
dans aucun objet
matériel
parce que Jésus
est venu
il n'est pas venu
nous donner
des pistes
pour qu'on puisse
comprendre
comment nous pouvons
nous assurer
que Dieu va nous traiter
avec paix
avec grâce
qu'est-ce que je dois faire
il n'a même pas
donné
tout simplement
son sacrifice
à la croix
pour payer
par nos punitions
ou son obéissance
parfaite
pour remplacer
notre manque d'obéissance
il s'est donné
la moindre suggestion
que nous devons encore
faire quelque chose
que nous devons donner
de l'importance
à quoi que ce soit
la moindre sensation
qu'on puisse traverser
des pensées
qui
un rituel
de l'eau bénie
de l'huile
une campagne
que je ne peux pas
rater
un dimanche
entre 70
et vous connaissez
ma position
un voile
sur la tête
peu importe
quoi que ce soit
qu'on puisse penser
qui peut me faire
mériter
la grâce
des dieux
mériter
la paix
des dieux
la faveur
c'est car Christ
n'est pas
le seul object
devant nos yeux
c'est car
Jésus Christ
n'est pas
suffisant
dans sa pleine beauté
je pense qu'il faut
encore quelque chose
d'autre
le travail
de l'apôtre ici
c'est de disparaître
et de dire
la seule médiation
entre vous
et la grâce
et la paix
des dieux
c'est Jésus Christ
il s'est donné
et qui s'est donné
c'est notre
Seigneur
Jésus Christ
c'est les rois
des rois
c'est celui
qui a déterminé
même la loi
pour nous
bon
tenez la loi
c'est ça
que j'attendais vous
pour que vous
soyez bien avec Dieu
personne ne peut accomplir
ok
donc maintenant
je viens
le Seigneur
de la loi
et il accomplit la loi
il est Jésus
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
sauveur
donc il est venu
pour nous sauver
et comment il nous a sauvés
il nous a donné
une oeuvre parfaite
oui
mais plus que ça
il s'est donné
lui-même
les sauveurs
c'est en lui
que nous vivons
la vie chrétienne
nous sommes connectés
à Jésus Christ
les Seigneurs
les sauveurs
les victorieux
les tout-puissants
une oeuvre a été déclenchée
pour nous
qui n'a pas
de marche en arrière
par les Seigneurs
des Seigneurs
pour nous sauver
pour nous sanctifier
pour nous glorifier
aucune chose
ne peut empêcher
et c'est aussi
les Christ
les Messies
si tu as entendu
c'est lui qui allait
accomplir l'oeuvre parfaite
se présenter
en tant que sacrifice
mourir
ressusciter
et revenir
pour nous chercher
pour juger
tout l'univers
qui s'est donné
en entier
il ne s'est pas donné
en moitié
il s'est donné
par nécessité
d'un côté
mais il s'est donné
exagérément
plus
car
son oeuvre
était parfaite
c'est
ce serait suffisant
mais c'est
les fils
des dieux
lui-même
et donc
nous sommes adoptés
dans la famille
des dieux
sans la moindre
possibilité
que notre condition
d'enfance
soit ébranlée
c'est lui
qui s'est donné
pour qu'on soit
conforme à lui
donc aucun autre
élément
ne pourrait
devenir
un fondement
et Jésus
n'est pas seulement
le fondement
il est
la totalité
de notre vie
chrétienne
c'est en lui
que nous
trouvons notre salut
et notre progression
spirituelle
donc il est
le fondement
de notre foi
et l'objectif
de l'évangile
c'est celui
de nous arracher
du présent siècle
mauvais
l'objectif
de l'évangile
c'est la rédemption
ou la restauration
pleine
de son peuple
et de tout
l'univers
l'objectif
de l'évangile
est la rédemption
la restauration
pleine
car Paul va dire ici
de la part
des dieux
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
qui s'est donné
lui-même
pour nos péchés
afin de
nous arracher
du présent siècle
mauvais
donc Jésus
il s'est donné
personne
comme disent
les puritans
personne
n'oserait
imaginer
que Christ
le fils
de Dieu
lui-même
incarné
pour mourir
dans une croix
serait la réponse
à notre condition
personne
n'oserait
imaginer
et plus que ça
personne
n'oserait
proposer
même si on avait
imaginé
qui aurait
le courage
de dire
Dieu
je pense
que je suis arrivé
à la conclusion
je pense
que s'il faut
que l'humanité
soit sauvée
il faut que tu
envas ton fils
pour mourir
la croix
que Dieu
traverse
la douleur
de perdre
son enfant
bien-aimé
qui aurait
osé
proposer
ça
à Dieu
et les pères
a voulu
les fils
s'est porté
volontaire
et les fils
s'est donné
et pourquoi
nous sommes là
en train de penser
que nous pouvons
présenter
quoi que ce soit
à Dieu
afin d'améliorer
notre position
devant lui
nous ne pourrions
jamais présenter
quelque chose
de meilleur
que Jésus
la réalité
est qu'aucune chose
de moins que Jésus
ne serait capable
de nous sauver
et donc ici
nous voyons
qu'il s'est donné
de manière volontaire
avec un objectif précis
pour
il s'est donné
pour nos péchés
afin de nous arracher
du présent siècle
mauvais
et là
les termes
bibliques
il est très important
il est très riche
c'est
le terme
aéon
pour décrire
les mondes
ou siècle
présent
et bon
on va traduire
comme siècle
car cette manière
de parler du monde
elle met l'emphase
dans la présente
condition du monde
c'est à dire
un monde
qui est corrompu
qui est en train
de se détériorer
et donc
ce qui va faire
en fait
c'est toutes ces couches
des définitions
de termes
donc nous arracher
du présent siècle
mauvais
arracher
ou nous délivrer
et c'est un terme
très riche aussi
qui peut signifier
non seulement
arracher
ou déraciner
mais délivrer
et sauver
et c'est les tons
majeurs
de la lettre
c'est la lettre
de l'émancipation
et délivrer
c'est les mots du jour
et quand on voit
les poids
de cette conception
arracher
du présent siècle
mauvais
l'emphase
elle est claire
il est là
non seulement
pour mourir
pour nos péchés
c'est à dire
effacer notre dette
payer les prix
nous délivrer
de l'enfer
enlever la coupabilité
non
il est là
il a déclenché
une oeuvre
qui non seulement
nous délivre
de la condamnation
mais qui nous arrache
du monde présent
et donc
il y a un double
emphase ici
très contrastante
qui va mettre
l'emphase du fait
que nous sommes encore
dans un monde mauvais
corrompu
mais qui nous assure
qu'ils nous seront
progressivement
déracinés
de ces mondes
voilà la caractéristique
primaire du chrétien
c'est quelqu'un
qui n'est plus du monde
mais qui vit dans les mondes
qui n'arrive pas
à s'accrocher trop
au plaisir
de cette vie
qui a toujours
la sensation
que les choses
que Dieu peut offrir
pendant saison
peut être retirées
un peu plus tard
et que toutes les choses là
sont en train de contribuer
pour qu'on soit plus attaché
au paradis
qu'à la réalité présente
c'est pour qu'on développe
chaque fois plus d'intimité
avec notre cité céleste
notre vraie citoyenneté
et malheureusement
nous allons traverser
un corps
un temps
dans ces mondes corrompus
un monde corrompu
et à nouveau
comme j'ai dit
dans les offrandes
donc nous sommes responsables
pour tous les malheurs
qui sont là
mais à partir du moment
que nous sommes en Christ
nous savons
que nous ne devons pas
trop nous coupabiliser
il faut nous rappeler
que Dieu a fixé un jour
pour tout restaurer
et pour tout juger
mais les chrétiens
seront pendant les temps
de la passante de Dieu
encore exposés
au même malheur
que les non-chrétiens
nous allons voir
nos corps déterrurer
nous allons souffrir
des maladies
nous allons voir
les gémissements
du monde
les catastrophes
les plaies
nous allons traverser
des décès
et nous ne pouvons pas
développer
une posture romantique
envers ces mondes
la plupart des souffrances
qui traversent
les chrétiens
sont prévenantes
d'anticipation
des promesses
qui Dieu n'a jamais faites
les présents siècles
est corrompu
c'est des terreurs
Jésus va utiliser
l'expression
vous êtes la lumière
du monde
vous êtes
les sels de la terre
les sels
pour freiner
légèrement
quelque chose d'inévitable
la poutréfaction
progressive
de ces mondes
la lumière
pour nous rappeler
que la
la sensation
prédominante
c'est que
les ténèbres
sont là
donc c'est un monde
corrompu
c'est un monde
qui se détériore
et nous devons
développer
dès le départ
jusqu'à la fin
de notre foi
la capacité
et bien sûr
que les manifestations
de la présente condition
du monde
puissent
nous attrister
comme c'est nécessaire
c'est inévitable
mais que nous ne soyons
ni exagérément
coupabilisés
victimisés
car
nous ne pouvons
surtout pas
connecter
nos détresses
nos difficultés
nos crises
nos souffrances
à notre performance
personnelle
surtout pas
après la conversion
par la grâce
de Dieu
s'il faut que Dieu
corrige un enfant
c'est comme on perd
si quelqu'un
est un Christ
tout est payé
la seule chose
qu'il ne veut pas
qu'on développe
lorsqu'on traverse
les manifestations
de la méchanceté
de ces mondes
c'est de penser
que nous sommes
en train de sortir
du cadre
de la faveur de Dieu
de la paix
de Dieu
car Christ
a tout accompli
pour nous arracher
et de l'autre côté
l'emphase
n'est pas qu'émise
sur la réalité
qui nous laisserait
dans un pessimisme
énorme
mais les chrétiens
il est marqué
plutôt par l'optimisme
les chrétiens
il doit être marqué
par l'anticipation
des bénédictions
de Dieu
car les bénédictions
les plus importantes
sont déjà là
la présence
du Saint-Esprit
et la conviction
qui sait que Dieu
réserve pour nous
vers les futurs
est toujours mieux
pour nous
qu'aujourd'hui
et qui même
les détresses
concourent au bien
de ceux
qui aiment Dieu
et donc
si vous pouvez
me suivre
dans une imagination
moi
quand je vois
l'oeuvre du Christ
accomplie à la croix
et quand je vois
ces tremblements
des terres
qui a eu lieu
et ces morts
qui sont ressuscités
dans ces moments là
et les voiles déchirés
je vois clairement
que la nouvelle création
a été inaugurée
vous savez
dans ces films là
quand on
un tremblement
des terres
d'une large magnitude
a lieu
et qu'on a l'impression
qu'il y a une vague
d'impact
qui va s'éparpiller
partout dans le monde
c'est qu'il crie sa faire
la croix
c'est les déclenchements
d'une restauration
pleine
et pendant que Christ
est en train
de restaurer
l'âme des chrétiens
à l'image
des dieux
développer
cette intimité
interne
invisible
à partir de l'église
envers les mondes
perdus
il y a un Jésus
qui s'apprête
à revenir en même temps
pour tout restaurer
pour ce qui concerne
les matériels
et ces mondes
mauvais
à ces jours comptés
l'église dit
Maranatha
vient Seigneur Jésus
nous traversons
chaque période
des détresses
en anticipant
la prochaine bénédiction
mais surtout
en anticipant
l'assurance
qu'un jour
ces gémissements
vont finir
et les jours
de l'accouchement
de la nouvelle création
dans sa pleine restauration
aura lieu
voilà pourquoi
les chrétiens
ne peuvent pas
trop se victimiser
quand ils voient
ils savent
qu'on va traverser
des douleurs
mais voilà pourquoi
les chrétiens
vont être beaucoup
plus marqués
par l'optimisme
par l'anticipation
des bénédictions
que par
l'accablement
des situations
difficiles
qu'on traverse
c'est la restauration
pleine
qui est déjà assurée
et c'est l'objectif
de Paul envers les Galates
il nous a
opéré cette œuvre
merveilleuse
pour nous arracher
du présent siècle
mauvais
et c'est là
selon la volonté
de notre Dieu
et Père
donc l'origine
de l'évangile
c'est la grâce
des dieux
c'est quelque chose
qu'on avait déjà
pas mal touché
l'origine
c'est la grâce des dieux
volonté du fils
volontaire
volonté du père
aussi volontaire
détermination
des dieux
pour nous arracher
Trinité
travaillant
ensemble
les pères
qui définit
les plans
qui envoient les fils
les fils
qui va
volontaire
qui exécute
les saluts
les saint esprit
qui opère
volontaire
et qui nous sauve
et qui commence
à nous arracher
et qui continue
jusqu'au rétour du Christ
donc les pères
Dieu n'était pas
en train de regarder
en dehors de soi-même
pour trouver des motivations
pour nous sauver
les pères
à contempler
l'infinie richesse
de sa grâce
et à trouver des motivations
pour nous aimer
il a décidé
de nous aimer
voilà pourquoi
il n'y a aucune chose
qu'on puisse faire
à gauche
ou à droite
pour qu'on soit plus
ou moins aimé par Dieu
Dieu nous a décidé
d'aimer son peuple
tel qu'il aime
son propre fils
car lorsqu'il nous voit
il nous voit couverts
du Christ
et c'est ça
qui provoque en Dieu
son amour pour nous
et en même temps
nous progressons
en conformité
avec Jésus Christ
et nous pouvons
provoquer du plaisir
dans la gloire de Dieu
progressivement aussi
mais c'est
l'origine de l'évangile
et la grâce de Dieu
et la dernière chose
c'est de considérer
que les résultats
suprêmes
de l'évangile
sont la gloire
exclusive
rendue à Dieu
donc il va conclure
l'apôtre Paul
et c'est la conclusion
pour nous aussi
selon la volonté
de notre Dieu
et Père
et là c'est intéressant
car jusqu'ici
il est en train
de parler
des dieux
les Pères
maintenant c'est
Dieu
notre Père
à qui soit la gloire
au siècle
des siècles
Amen
pour ce qui concerne
la correction au Galate
ce que Paul
est en train de faire
c'est tout simplement
de dire
l'évangile
n'est pas passif
d'amélioration
l'évangile est parfait
il est capable
de provoquer
la gloire à Dieu
au siècle
des siècles
car cette oeuvre
elle est parfaite
dans une définition
précise
et dans toutes
ses facettes
en Jésus Christ
pour ce qu'il a fait
pour ce qu'il est
pour l'amour
des dieux manifestés
pour nous
mais aussi
par la plénitude
et l'impact
de cette oeuvre
qui va tout restaurer
en gloire
et ce qu'il pourrait
être en train de dire
ni pour que vous soyez
sauvés
complètement restaurés
vous avez pu
contribuer
avec aucune autre chose
à part votre péché
nous avons contribué
avec les péchés
Dieu a contribué
avec tout
et lorsque nous
comprenons
de manière
correcte
les messages
de l'évangile
définis par les apôtres
lorsque nous comprenons
ces messages
et que cela
est couplé
au travail
de Saint-Esprit
pour qu'on soit capable
de discerner la vérité
c'est impossible
que la vérité
ne déclenche pas
les affections correctes
et l'adoration
n'est rien
qu'une réponse
naturelle
spontanée
à la contemplation
de la gloire
de l'évangile
je ne peux pas
m'élever
et dire
à toutes les personnes
dans une salle
et dire
dites gloire à Dieu
car si c'est quelque chose
de mécanique
je suis en train
de répéter
des expressions
c'est pas l'attitude
biblique
le compte de la Bible
on dit
que tous les êtres
qui ont
des lames
chantent à l'éternel
là ils sont en train
de vivre
et d'expérimenter
une joie
incroyable
et ils sont juste
dans les désirs
qu'on puisse voir
ce qu'ils voient
et ce qui nous fait voir
ce qui provoque
l'adoration
c'est la parole
de Dieu
enregistrée par les apôtres
c'est un évangile
défini dans sa gloire
magistrale
et lorsqu'il est
Saint-Esprit
nous aide à comprendre
la gloire de l'évangile
les résultats
et l'adoration
c'est d'arriver à la conclusion
et c'est l'objectif
de Paul
Paul ici
il est authentique
dans cette adoration
il va rompre avec
ses écrits
pour adorer à Dieu
c'est très commun
en Paul
c'est quelqu'un
qui adorait
authentiquement à Dieu
il ne pouvait pas méditer
à l'oeuvre du Christ
pour nous
sans déclencher
en adoration
mais il y a aussi
quelque chose
que Paul veut
qu'on corrige
dans nos vies
et ce qu'on doit
corriger dans nos vies
c'est de nous rappeler
que l'évangile
il est parfait
il n'a pas besoin
d'amélioration
de nos contributions
c'est cette correction
qu'il vise à apporter
c'est un évangile
que nous ne pouvons pas
développer
ni améliorer
de la vie